er redet manchmal so ein bisschen um den
heißen brei herum aber er wird der
sympathische in meinen augen habe ich
heute nicht einen
zupackenden minister erlebt sondern
einen kandidaten
denn auch wenn jens spahn sagt dass er
sich mit laschet geeinigt hat
auf den vize posten
zwar ist es doch gibt es habe ich gehört
ja in der cdu in der union gibt es
bestrebungen
insider habe ich das gesagt habe mir das
gesagt dass man sich vorstellen könnte
lasche zu bewegen auch wenn ich leicht
zugunsten von herrn spahn
vielleicht ich zurück zieht also dass
genau das stattfindet nämlich ein
wechsel der positionen und ich könnte
mir so einen jungen cdu-vorsitzenden
sehr gut vorstellen
und viele haben mir nachgesagt dass emma
karrierist ist und immer nur versucht
den nächsten schritt anzupeilen und
diese rolle als gesundheitsminister tut
die wir eigentlich im moment ganz gut
weil er das nicht machen kann er muss
tatsächlich regierungspolitik umsetzen
er muss musste seriös sacharbeit leisten
was ja auch sehr gut kann er kommt ja
aus diesem bereich und im team mit
laschet hat er sich ein sollte er seine
zweite position er weiß auch dass er
diese position jetzt nicht infrage
stellen kann er kann nicht aus dieser
rolle angreifen heraus weil das all das
wieder zunichte machen würde was er
bisher erreicht hat also ich würd mal
sagen jetzt sparen würde sich nicht
ärgern wenn man ihn bitten würde am ende
derjenige zu sein der kanzlerkandidat
oder parteichef werden soll
aber er kann von seiner rolle aus herr
nur seine sache so gut wie möglich
machen und warten was andere dann
vielleicht eher nehmen daran tragen er
hat im moment glaube ich keine andere
möglichkeit es wäre auch kein smarter
move jetzt nach vorne zu preschen er hat
dort sein wort gegeben das hat er heute
hier auch noch mal bekräftigt und es
wäre alles andere als schlau sich jetzt
da ins spiel zu bringen wenn mich nicht
alles täuscht gibt es ein cdu-parteitag
wenn sie ihn gibt und wenn mich nicht
alles täuscht die entspannt da gar nicht
an sondern es treten laschet märz und
röttgen an unterhalt und einer von denen
wird es das heißt armin laschet als
cdu-chef kann nur armin laschet
verhindern indem er die nerven verliert
oder indem er gedrängt wird die macht
die ihm damit zukommt nicht anzunehmen
so habe ich armin laschet nicht
wahrgenommen und übrigens dann wenn das
passiert kommt sofort die frage auf
warum sollen wir denn den jens nehmen
dann immer durch über den micro aus
bayern
da haben wir noch mehr chancen und
sozusagen auf eine formel gebracht einer
muss laschet killen wenn er sich nicht
selber gilt das kann nicht jens spahn
sein weil er dazu zu klug ist da
schließe ich mich an
aber dieses gebeten werden seinen
eigenen ich sage jetzt mal chef
sozusagen in diesem ensemble aus dem
rennen zu schubsen
daran glaube ich nicht vor allem mit
einem ganz banalen indiz jens spahn ist
40 der hat noch ganz ganz ganz ganz lang
zeit kanzler zu werden
armin laschet lich und deswegen glaube
ist auch wie es anderswo er da wird es
vielleicht nein erfreuen aber wenn ich
mich heute festlegen müsste würde ich
sagen
laschet wird und macht es auch ich
glaube schon dass auch das in die
zukunft denkt und er sich nicht als
lasche spahn gespannt sieht sondern eher
als spaß
wiederspahn oder sparen söder wie auch
immer
[Musik]